[Music]
foreign
zach renat thank you so much for joining
me at 20 minute leaders
it's great to be here oh yeah thanks
enough you know so actually i think
i think we this is actually aired a few
weeks after passover so
hugs now and already for the september
holidays in any case
yeah actually this this year i think you
know we all need to think about you know
the acts of those
and not just in the context of a
passover but
a lot more a lot bigger picture than
that a hundred percent so zach
we only have in 20 minutes it's not
nearly enough for what i want to cover
you're one of the most fascinating
people that i know and one of the most
accomplished entrepreneurs i can ever
think of and i'd love to
to sort of go through your journey from
you know all the way back from business
school
and how you started the variety of
various companies and experienced
different things throughout your
companies and then i want to move all
the way to culture and non-profits
so let's just start who are you as an
entrepreneur
yeah so you know my journey as an
entrepreneur actually started
before a kind of new business school
actually started
in the 90s when i worked on
a project actually to develop a jet
fighter
in israel called the de la ville and i
was
um a programmer at the time when i
worked on the
flight control computer of fidel v it
was a fascinating project
and then the project was cancelled by
the israeli
government and that really made a big
impact
on me my life plan was always to come to
the united states to get a phd in the
computer science
and when i graduated from the technion
in the
in the mid 80s i actually
applied to get the pga here in the
united states and i
was accepted wow they decided that i'm
going to
walk for a couple of years and then the
la vie really changed
change it and i decided that i'm not
going to let anyone control my
destiny anymore and then i am
applied to a single business school in
the united states
to harvard i've heard of it i got i got
in
so it was a very a naive uh
move at the time if you think about it
for perspective
applying to only one business school so
my wife and my son who was 15 months at
the time we packed 11 successes and
and came here wow so coming to business
school was part of
this notion of i really want to ransom
to business i want to control my
own destiny and i'm going to become
an entrepreneur and i came to a silicon
valley
in 1990 and then in
1995 i started my first companies with
their two other co-founders
it's a company called the next dynamics
we created the market for application
servers
the company was enormously successful
and then they got acquired by sun
microsystems
and then got acquired by oracle
and our work is known right now as a
standard that is called j2ee
java 2 enterprise edition wow
and then the right after i helped a
friend of mine
uh johan who was a professor at stanford
yeah i started another company called a
trading dynamics
and trading dynamics was a pioneering
business to business
auctions wow the company was in business
for about
18 months and then got acquired by ariba
18 months 18 months yeah this was a sign
of of a time actually it's a funny story
because
the company was uh going into beta
and zero revenues it was the height of
the dot-com boom and then we got a
proposal for
um to get the kauai by commerce one
and then a competition between
congresswoman
and ariba on the business
and ariba came in with an offer for 420
million dollars to
acquire the company after 18 hours the
board
was split at the the kind of
time if to you know sell the company
and because the management team came to
the board and said
why should we compromise on this low
ball
offer from ariba if we
get a half a million dollar in revenues
next year we're going
to get a market cup of four billion
dollars
you have to remember it's height of the
kind of the dot co
but nevertheless we uh california we
decided that
it's it's a good opportunity to you know
sell the kind of
the company zach 18 months i'm still at
the 18-month stage
yeah but you know you have you have to
remember
that i think this is always the
difference between
a watch and a compass so
in silicon valley we have a lot of time
titles so if you look at this at the
time
and you say what time it is and people
will tell you
well you know it's four o'clock and you
know because
you know we can get four billion dollars
in market cap you know next year
but if you have a compass if you have a
direction if you know where you are
going if you have a little bit of a
context you realize
that it's out of context uh you know
this kind of like this period of time
and by the way it was a stock swap
so once we conclude the deal it
turned to be from 400 million dollars to
720 million
and then it went over a billion dollar
for a period of kind of a period of time
wow um and then i
was also involved as the chairman of the
board and also
the first external money in the israeli
company
called conduit a conduit became to be
the
first israeli unicorn yeah
and then split it into a a privately
held company
and also to a publicly held company
through
a reverse merger with a company called
perion a network
it's still traded on california nasdaq
yeah
and my longest endeavor was with the
company called the
n that we founded in 99
and that's a company that was in the
business of revenue life cycle
management for
life sciences and high-tech companies
and it's a company that we took a public
on the new york stock exchange exactly
seven years ago
and it's still traded under the symbol
modeling
and before the corona virus the company
had
a market cup of about 1.2 billion
dollars
it's a lot less right now and
and three years ago i hired the ceo
i overlapped with email for three months
and then i relinquish all
my duties in the company as the ceo as a
chairman
as the board member and they move to the
next stage of my life and
you know right now we have a family
foundation and we call it the their
foundation
the their foundation okay so we're gonna
we're gonna get there very soon but
first
so if you how much how much value did
you really bring into the economy
into the world economy through these
different endeavors do you have some
some number of if you look at these
different ventures and how much
how much how much they brought into the
economy do you know about how much that
is
well you know i think you could look at
this from a lot of different
kind of different angles but one of the
areas that i
was always you know important for
economy for me is really
the quantity of jobs that
you create in the economy both the u.s
economy and the global economy
the nature of the business that you run
right now is
global in nature and it's not just the
companies that you create
and and the immediate jobs it also goes
beyond that in terms of the support
functions that the whole supply chain
yeah and and also in terms of working
with the system integrators that help
you to
uh implement the the software
and the partnership that that you create
and
i believe that the work
i created over the last 25 years so
my company is kind of recreated was
somebody in the kind of
the tens of thousands of of jobs and
actually it's a conflict of funny story
during the obama presidency
and the obama
president presidency and administration
was in the business of promoting
entrepreneurship
and promoting actually entrepreneurship
by
immigrants and they wanted to recognize
a people
so i was lucky and it's quite
unfortunate to be recognized by
the wildcard white house it's somebody
they call a champion
of change which is entrepreneurs they're
enabled to create
jobs in uh kind of know the in the in
the economy
no that's that's very different than you
know the current administration
unbelievable and so with all with all of
that i mean you do so many other things
and
and i just want to show i mean we really
got to meet really face to face at
burning man of last year
where you also you know and enjoy
culture and enjoy taking the time off
being with family or they're with your
wife and just enjoy
you know experiencing the world right
yeah so you know uh actually i i don't
know if you want to speak about the
details about you know where we're
at well we'll leave that for another
discussion
i think you know we should keep here as
a pg-13 100
of you but it was the special yeah so
over
over the last couple of years they
definitely became a kind of
burner and uh i love the event and for
me it's not just the event become to be
actually a way of
of life yeah we are a part of a
of a larger camp and it's really
interesting because
even now during the kind of not the
corona
um epidemic our
camp run basically almost a 27 by 24
um zoom yeah events and we have every
day we have a sound bus and meditation
and and camp dinners and
um parties and
and and variety of california varieties
so i think it's a
it's a wonderful event and it's a
wonderful
experience and i think that you know
actually i i don't know what you take
from me burning man but to me it's also
um
for me it's it's also it's a it's a
lesson in leadership
and and and about you know how you
create you know a context because
it creates such a an amazing
a bonding experience there
it removes the cynicism that we all have
about
people and and kind of know people and
kind of know people
nature and uh you can see that
if you work with even a large group of
of people and you set basically values
and you know the ten principles yeah and
you exemplify
and these they kind of know these they
kind of know these values
you know magic happens and that's the
same philosophy that you have about how
you work and you create the culture
in kind of you know in a kind of linear
company totally no you know one of the
things
that you know i've i went there with my
dad for quite a few times right now
and i remember when we got there the
first year i believe it was
2014 and we just stood there and we
couldn't believe
that there isn't a single piece of trash
in
the whole of the city you know 80 000
people
everything is moving around p it's not
that people are still people are moving
around things are being thrown in the
air
you look at the ground there is nothing
it's spotless clean and people take
pride in the context that they managed
to create
in this in this burning man world and so
let's move from that to the company
culture and so you've got to build
different companies with so many
different employees and you got to work
in all different industries with all
different types of people
what are some what sort of your two
cents on on
creating culture and and how do you go
about doing it and
and keeping yourself in check so you
know it's one thing to be the ceo and
the founder and to
say yeah i'm building culture and i'm
doing such and such but then
you know there's the ground level where
there's actually friction
so how do you actually keep yourself in
check over there
of course so first of all you know i'm
coming from a very um methodological way
of
building a kind of building culture
and i think that you know first of all i
believe that the culture needs to be
explicit not in kind of implicitly
because the culture that is uh implicit
it's
due to interpretation and
i also believe that there are two ways
to create cultures the first one
is to create it from the outside
in and that's
basically looking at making um a
statement about what the future you want
to be
in the what the culture you want to be
in the future
yeah and then you build the culture in
order to
kind of not to get there but i'm a more
believer that you need to look at this
you know from the inside
out and and why is this because i
believe that the
the foundation the building blocks for
culture
is about values and i think you really
need to look in yourself
and really understand what val
values you stand for and why is this
because we say that not
as a change is constant right that's the
slogan which has changed his concept but
the thing that values are pretty
constant too
i do not think that you know my values
has
changed for a very very long of time so
bill you know fundamental beliefs that
you have
for example about integrity about you
know not taking risks they do not change
you know
all the kind of all the time and how do
you make a situation i think you really
need
to look you know at yourself yeah and i
think it's something
that the founding team needs to go and
really need to
work with each other in order to
understand what it is that you stand for
i also come from actually the belief
that
if the founding team do not adhere
do not believe in the same values it's
not a good
actually founding team so part of the
the process is that when you start the
company and you have the founding team
you have to spend a lot of times about
what it is that you are going to uh kind
of need to stand for
and it's going to stay there for uh kind
of for a very long
period of time and and and and so on
and then i think that you know once you
understand what values you stand for you
need to you know write them down and you
need to think you know how you
communicate them right now you have to
understand that you know
culture you know in my mind it's not for
everyone
so for the people that um
you want to be in the company it feels
like home
but for other people it feels like
something that
um they don't belong to and good
cultures
are like a boundary it's like a border
that they
distinguish between insiders and
outsiders
and and why is this because when you
make a hiring mistake
in a company that has a distinct culture
it's immediately
noticeable and and these people are
basically
are leaving the company in a very short
period of time
and so when when we look at
the culture that we we said you know for
the companies that
i ran it always come to four core values
focal values came to the initials of
their d-a-r-e where this stands for
a dream a for a line
r for respect and if for example
and then i think it's really important
that you're going to hire
people that simplify the values
and and how do you do this i always
interviewed about
the first 250 people myself in
all the companies that that they run
because if you
get the management team right and if you
get
the first 200 people in the company
yeah to exemplify the values then every
you know magic can happen
and then the other thing about the
values is something that you need to
ingrain in everything that you do in the
company so we had
questions that were related to the core
values in the hiring process
it was part of the evaluation process of
paypal
it was part of the promotion that we set
for people
it was part of the compensation of
of people we had um bonuses that were
related to
meeting certain kpis that were related
to
a kind of law to the core values wow and
it's also something that
you promote for example every year
in in the company we had the process
of nomination evaluation
selection and verification of people
that
exemplify the core values and every year
we selected them based on geographic and
functions and so on and then always
there was one person
that was that selected as the one that
exemplified that the core values the
best in the last year
and it was not just a minor process as
it was
there was one time a year when i stood
in front of the company and there was
dead silence
and this was when we announced the
winner of the the spirit windows
wow and by the way we gave all these
people a pretty significant amount of
stock in the company okay so it's not
just the trophy it's actually it's
actually
yeah okay yeah and then you know the
other thing that is really important is
that
culture come into a play when you need
to make
tough decisions right that's not what
everything is up because
why is this because then you really need
to make a trade-off
that's a very painful trade-off
definitely and
i think these are really the events that
really set the collective memory
and the way of uh careful behavior for a
kind of love for the company
no no it's zach it's incredible i mean
we could go on this for four hours
unfortunately
we're almost we're almost done but i i
have to get in
in a minute what is how do you how did
you take this concept of their
d-a-r-e and then transition it into
a non-profit movement where you're
actually impacting
a lot of different people right now so
tell me just a little bit about that
so i'll tell you kind of knowing you
know a funny story
and i was fortunate
to expect to to serve
in the special forces and the israeli
defense forces
and we had the slogan and the slogan
is theirs wins and
there is actually not something that was
invented in israel
it was invented actually by a british
unit called
the sas they had a
legendary commander called david
sterling known as the ghost colonel
and in world war ii they invented the
moderating
warfare for the special forces they
dressed as the germans they stole german
cars they
went into german camps and and so on and
congress slogan
was also who there is a win yeah and
if you think about you know consistency
of values from you know the military
through business
and now through social impact
um i also had a very long time plan
that um i will you know be in business
and then
i will turn into a social
entrepreneurship
and and give back uh what i got
experience and network and
and resources and and try to do it in
in a different context yeah so their
foundation is the the same notion of
trying to make some bold you know social
change
um in kind of knowing a different kind
of environment
and encourage social entrepreneurs
to go and to take some risky endeavors
and try to make a difference and
that's what we are trying to do now in
the social world
no exactly it's just it's it's
incredible so right before we finish
uh it's something that i ask everybody
and i'm especially curious to hear
your thoughts on this what are three
words that
looking back you think best describe you
or that you think
you know the thousands of people that
you've worked with and interacted with
would describe you as
um i think i just said they may think
who dares
wins okay i think that's i think that's
just perfect
zach thank you so so much i think what
it is i think i think that you know
if you want to you know
make a big difference you need to dare
you need to uh kind of know you need to
take uh a risk
you need to have uh the kind of the
confidence and
yeah kind of knowing kind of yourself
and if you dare
you win no no i think it's just it's
amazing you know it
everybody can talk the talk and when
everything goes well and everybody's
happy then it's easy to
to act and to go forward but when it's a
little bit more challenging and when
you're facing
these different tasks especially as a
founder and as a ceo
that's where that's the real test and uh
and
i mean i feel very very lucky for this
relationship and thank you for
thank you for for being a friend and a
mentor and for joining
this project um zach just thank you
yeah thank you and thank you for the the
opportunity of course
bye-bye thanks america again